make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are continuing on with our
discussion on the boys yes we are as
always if you guys want to see the
uncensored version make sure you go
check out my patreon patreon comm slash
comics explained I've also got my
monthly comic book review show that's on
there and I've got the vs. video so the
guys who were curious about the vs.
videos and you want to know whether it's
worth it or not the last one we did I
think was Franklin Richards versus dr.
Manhattan and I think the next one were
probably gonna do is Franklin Richards
versus Matthew Molloy you guys really
seem to love like the super Opie
characters versus the super Opie
characters so like I think we're gonna
stick with those for a while but yeah so
so continuing on with the boys
this basically picks up initially with
really kind of like the aftermath of
everything with like hero gasm and all
the stuff that we'd covered up to this
point uh keep in mind chronologically it
does kind of take place before the
origin stories but one of the things we
talked about there with the origins is
that they weren't really tied into any
existing story they were just kind of
self-contained so we could have done
those pretty much whenever we probably
should've done them in the beginning to
be honest but what this does is it
basically deals with with the boys
essentially showing up and targeting one
of the superhero teams now again this is
the boys kind of continuing to send out
a message right sort of keep the
superheroes on their on their toes up
but to also be one of those things worse
like we're not a group to mess around
with understand the message that's
coming to you and so what it does is it
basically shows these guys roughed up
quite readily I mean there's really not
a whole lot Garth Ennis does here
because they're not really designed to
be the main draw it's really just
designed to show us the boys and in
their most pure form smashing heads in
with baseball bats
the females ripping off another chicks
face I mean it's pretty gruesome and
it's pretty extreme but it's just
designed for the purpose of sending a
message that's really all it's designed
to do and this is the reason why the
boys are so dangerous right we talked
about this before on multiple occasions
when we've discussed the nature of the
boys right I mean they are a clandestine
team in so much as they're hard to find
but they are well known by the selling
right they've had dealings in the past
and things like that home lander knows
exactly who these guys are and so it's
one of these things because the question
that people kind of ask and there's
something easy to forget but one of the
questions people ask is why don't they
just kill the boys and again it all
really kind of comes down to the
information they have and we'll talk
about that here in a little bit once we
get to that appropriate section but what
it does is it jumps over to kind of like
the marketing side of Vaud America now
remember unlike the TV show bought
American isn't really as on-the-nose in
the comic as they are in the in the TV
show in the TV show you kind of get like
an American right there front and center
and you pretty much see them for what
they are in the in the comics are kind
of like this clandestine organization
that exists out there and they're just
the ones that are essentially in charge
of the money when it comes to their
superheroes the one that we're the ones
that write their stories they they
construct how their other comics are
going to function all that kind of stuff
they're really like the marketing side
of things but for the most part up to
this point we don't really know much
about them their inner workings how it
all functions or anything like that so
there's something that I wanted to kind
of point out a lot of the guys have
asked questions over the course of the
videos like why aren't you covering what
goes on with Vaught American because we
don't really know right the comics that
you know the bought American functions
differently or at least has shown
differently in the comics than it isn't
a TV show but it's kind of want to point
that out for some of you guys who were
asking that question but one of the big
things that goes on here is that von
America has really sort of come in with
the notion of saying hey like we're
gonna basically assign new costumes to
everybody right light everybody gets new
costumes that already gets new outfits
and everybody gets new origins this is
explicitly in response to the fact that
the voice took out the demon if you guys
remember our last video on that the boys
had basically taken the team out and the
result is that with the demon
essentially being gone here you know
kind of like the the x-men more or less
as they function in the in the boys the
result is that because they were the
highest-selling team now the seven kind
of have to make up for those lack of
sales by having like their there's their
origin stories relaunched and they're
having like new outfits things like that
basically it's kind of like you know
Garth Ennis his way of saying this is
what Americans way of kind of providing
new number-ones and kind of book form
right you know you for most of you guys
who have been reading comics for a while
you know that new number ones always
sell more than than anything that's not
a number one that new origin stories
always perform well and lot Americans
well aware of that both in terms of it
the superhero comics as you're being
sold within the story as well as how the
public perceives superheroes right so
when Von American comes out and says hey
everybody like we've got updated origins
for everyone and the the seven go out
there and they basically parade in a
teller news story or some part of their
story that nobody knew before is very
titillating and a lot of people are
really interested in that kind of stuff
right they want to know as much about
the superheroes as they possibly can and
so that's kind of the basis behind this
the issue that you run into here is that
a lot of the along not really all of
them but for the most part the ones who
have been part of the seven for a little
while are kind of like okay it's
business as usual we're gonna change
costumes I did they sort of just go with
the flow right because the one rule they
have there is don't mess with the money
fought American is the one that pays
their appease their bills broad American
is the one that gives them a place to
live and at any moment bought American
immediately take one of these
superheroes off the seventh film into
some kind of secondary team and then
that's it by some tertiary team that
exists out there and their entire career
so to speak as a superhero would be over
and even a homeland himself it's kind of
getting tired of Vaud American but he's
kind of getting getting irritated by it
and actually considers killing some of
them the results is that if that
happened vaughn american will just pull
the plug and the superheroes would be
screwed right they just kind of be left
hanging and whenever would happen would
happen
and so from there what it does is it
sort of transitions over to the female
who's basically given a tip you know
who's essentially told by hey by her
handlers here's the target we need you
to take care of now remember this is an
important role to understand when it
comes to the female that much like
Mother's Milk much like Huey the
Frenchie and even Billy butcher himself
that while they are part of the boys and
they do go on their missions to take out
superheroes they do also have a life on
the side but they have other things that
they engage in and insulin so forth
Huey's got his relationship with
starlight and whatever goes on with
these various characters the female is a
hitman for the mob right if that's what
a job she basically kills people for the
mob and so the result is that the mob
simply essentially tasked her with going
to this location and then taking out you
know whoever this target happens to be
only for us to find out that it's
actually Stormfront now we will get an
explanation on whose storefront is I
will provide that to you guys in this
video but in the in term at the moment
basically Stormfront absolutely wrecks
the female like literally tears her
apart and and essentially just like
beats are unconscious and so his ability
to take on and to basically take out the
female leads to her essentially you know
being tumbled into a coma and basically
being taken out now from that point it
goes directly into into starlight
starlight of course having your meeting
with with WOD American they're basically
going around around the offices more or
less of the seven saying hey here's your
new origin story here's your new costume
so on and so forth
they've run up on starlight and this is
one of the most controversial parts
because what they basically do is they
say hey looked like we're gonna give you
a new costume and everything but you're
also gonna get a new origin story right
your costume is gonna be a lot more
sultry because women who are drawn in
and very like sexually revealing clothes
are very attractive to young boys who
reconyx right so if we're gonna have you
wear this this outfit you're gonna be
very revealing in your physical
appearance and it's kind of a crazy
thing to sort of come out with because
the you know when she really turns
against it and says no I don't want to
have anything to do with this the
responses of on American guys is yeah
but like that's what sells though and
it's one of these things whereof on
America doesn't really care about who
the superheroes are as people bought
American cares about making money right
it's the only thing they
care about is money and so because of
that thought Americans just one of these
things works like I mean sure you may
disagree with it but either you can be
on board with it or you can get the boot
and be replaced on the 7 and that's one
of the things that Starlights really
been struggling with over time as part
of the senate it's kind of like how far
is she willing to go right I mean we've
seen how far she's willing to go and in
comparison to what she did in the
beginning of the story having a sultry
costume like that doesn't really seem to
compare to that is a pretty eager Ally
shaking thing to have done because what
it does is it really forces her to come
to the reality yet again then in terms
of what Americans she doesn't really
matter right she's just a means to
produce money and really you know it may
be that where she came from the squeaky
wheel gets the grease but as far as far
as what Americans concerned the squeaky
wheel gets replaced and that's really
kind of how she's she's understanding
really coming to terms with her role
within the Southern itself the other big
part of this and this is kind of a
significant thing here is that where you
end up having the boys who were to sort
of cutting up and they're having a
conversation and so on and so forth the
Frenchie basically comes in with this
sad face and then in turn tells them
that the females been taken out now this
is kind of a cool thing it's one of the
reasons why Mother's Milk is such an
important character here is because when
they go to the hospital where the
Frenchie took the female and their
intern kind of like alright you know
let's let's figure out what's going on
and they're talking about the revenge
they're gonna get Mother's Milk starts
looking around and says I got a question
for you guys and they say okay and they
say you guys notice that this this is a
hospital right and the response is like
yeah it's like but you don't really see
anybody else here you see a couple
nurses downstairs and there's a doctor
kind of roaming around but there's not
like a hospital full of medical staff
which is what you would expect like if
you go downstairs and you go to look for
those two nurses that we saw when they
came in what do you think the chances
are they're actually going to be there
and this is one of the coolest things
because what this shows is as a setup
that Vaught american when they were
talking to homeland earlier and homeland
it was like look you guys do your thing
just don't hurt the dog of Dilli butcher
because if you do all hell's gonna break
loose just the one thing you don't touch
that belongs to billy butcher and then
what bought american is essentially done
was basically go to storm front kind of
initiate this whole thing was they went
to storm front and then in turn storm
front took out took out the female and
then of course french she brought the
female to this location believing it was
a hospital only to turn around and find
out that it's basically just one great
big huge trap that's been set up and
then immediately a payback the group
that homefront as a part of comes flying
in and this great big huge fight breaks
out now this is where things get a
little crazy here is because what these
guys pay back begin to realize is that
by messing with the boys and explicitly
billy butcher that they've been off more
than they
- quite literally because literally
billy butcher bites off a guy's nose he
body he bites off soldier boy's nose
which is which is kind of wild
the issue here is you're talking about
some pretty powerful heavy hitters and
so the boys are taking as much damage as
payback itself and of course you have
storm front on the shona on the scene
meaning that they really kind of like
have this really solid heavy hitter on
their side the boys end up having to
retreat now Billy butcher basically
takes off alongside Huey for the purpose
of drawing the superheroes al Crimson
countess of course ended up following
Billy butcher and then once she actually
gets out to an alleyway only to see the
dog where she goes to attack it Billy
butcher comes up behind her and
strangles her and that's when everybody
begins to panic because they realized
Billy butcher killed the Crimson
countess and then from there one of the
guys she was able to kind of establish
his telepathic link through through it
through criminal counters herself
instead of getting this kind of phrase
basically that that comes through Billy
butcher where he says like you guys are
next and so essentially like it's it's
kind of a crazy moment here and this is
one of the reasons why build a butcher
is so awesome because on the surface you
would look at this and you would say
okay so like basically you have the
Frenchie and you have Huy who are
loading up mother's milk into the back
of an ambulance all three of those guys
are gonna take off and he was like neo
building butchers in there it's five on
one and in front she turns around and
says yeah they're stuck in there with
him I almost kind of feel bad for right
it's like that scene from the watching
you with were shocked where he's like
I'm not sucking here with you you guys
are locked in here with me this fight is
only gonna end one way and I promise
it's not gonna go the way that you think
it is one of the coolest things because
from there
Billy butcher basically just starts like
going through and getting out of each
one of these guys piecemeal and that's
the cool thing about it and it's the
reason why bill a butcher is such a
great character right because Billy
butcher is more than capable of being
able to handle himself and it's kind of
this thing you haven't really seen up to
this point right I mean you've seen him
fight and you've seen him do well and so
on and so forth you know but for the
most part it almost kind of seemed like
Billy butcher had this sort of skill set
about him that you could kind of feel
was there but didn't really have any
indication I didn't really see it
actually play out I was always kind of
the question what happens if like Billy
butcher's the last man standing if he's
like a cornered a cornered dog like how
badly is he going to lash out and he
does it in spectacular fashion the first
thing he does is grind up glass after
that he starts going after all the
various guys and it's kind of crazy here
because the first person to try to track
him down is storefront really butcher
basically grabs shards of glass throws
him in his eyes and blinds the one eye
he has left or at least you know appears
to blind it and then in turn starts
going through and using gorillas
or fair tactics to take each one of
these guys out now this is why Billy
butcher is so smart because the stupid
thing to do would be to like go in
against all of them head-on right like
that's guarantee death is a suicide run
because you are really talking about
like all these guys facing off against
Billy butcher some of whom have powers
and some of whom don't they would tear
them apart but when he goes through and
basically starts playing shadow games
when he starts intimidating them trying
to instill fear in them being in the
darkness not really being able to be
seen but talking to them and they in
turn begin to kind of get nervous it
basically starts to break their
willpower down break down their their
confidence it's a genius move it's very
Batman s cry just what Batman does and
so all these guys start kind of getting
taken out like - these guys ended up
making their way through the
construction site and when they turn a
corner there's a third guy there who
basically been bash to the head through
it with a pickaxe it's just like stand
like just sitting there right so it's
just like there's nowhere they can go to
safe but the fact if this guy died and
they didn't even really know until they
turn the corner and saw it it's kind of
a kind of a crazy moment here right like
Billy Richard runs upon and on the
second guy runs up on the on soldier boy
with a shovel and then it's like cracks
his head basically like like cracks him
over the head with it each one of these
guys basically starts getting taken out
and where they're begging for their life
he doesn't care he's just kinda like
whatever it doesn't really matter each
one of you guys is going to fall here
each one of you guys is gonna pay the
price and it's kind of a crazy thing
because from there the only person who
seems to have been left standing is the
guy who basically took off which is
Stormfront himself and that's when Huey
asked a question what's the deal with
storm front and this is a cool thing
about it this is when we get that
history then what we learn is that with
von american messing around like
compound v which has been around since
world war ii that what had happened is
that during the during the days of the
nazis but basically you know the germans
had taken compound v and then in turn
used to end storm front was the only
real successful subject that they had
the only real person he was who was able
to actually utilize compound v and
become any measure with superpowers the
issue is he literally grew up in that
german world war ii environment and
adopted all their mindsets now
ultimately with the fall of germany with
a cold war initiating different things
like that and and and ultimately bought
american kind of rising to prominence as
this supplier of superheroes and and
really the only only major source of
real compound v that was out there storm
front was essentially handed over the
bought american and became a part of the
various superhero teams that are out
there but the issue is that when they
look at that the explanation given to
Huey is this guy is no joke
kicking this guy on is no small thing
and that's really one of the things that
was realized is that if they're gonna
take on storm front they can't play
softball right they got to be in its for
winning any shaken confidence any shaken
an end resolved could potentially get
all of them killed and so what they end
up doing is basically launching this
attack and ultimately like pretty much
all of them as all of them seem to fall
except for Billy butcher and that's kind
of the cool thing here is because Billy
butchers is this guy with this huge
amount of resolve right like this desire
to take out superheroes it's the thing
that drives him and so you know he's
able to hold his own against one of the
more powerful guys out there which is
huge it's a big deal following that you
end up having mothers know who gets back
up you have Frenchie who gets back up
and they jump back into the fight again
and it basically just kind of revolt or
dissolves down into like this
three-on-one situation and they're
almost kind of taunting him right about
like the germans during world war ii and
yeah like you know you guys had the
upper hand at first and then the world
turned against you and all of you felt
right like it's it's you know it's kind
of a cool little thing because what you
end up getting here is basically Voss
from the glorious five-year plan and
basically fights alongside the boys to
take out is it to basically eliminate
storm front but that's basically yet you
know the whole thing essentially wraps
up in so far as like once he's done and
gone like he's essentially defeated here
right like there is no more payback the
team is is basically destroyed and and
eliminated not only that the guy who
appeared to have been running bought
American died of a heart attack in the
sauna right so this member of autumn
erican who's been spending time with
with homeland and talking to him appears
to be the guy who's gonna be running the
show now which is kind of a big deal
because the question becomes what role
is he gonna play and so with the female
still in a coma ultimately while other
white is recovering and he starts
snacking on a piece of candy suddenly
she wakes up writes a suddenly she comes
to and so where all the boys begin to
kind of celebrate the fact that the
females back now that she's not
permanently stuck in a coma hillbilly
butcher basically leaves and says okay I
got to take care of some business only
for us to find out that Billy butcher
kept soldier boy alive he's got to
chained up in a room he walks in there
with a with a with a giant like
butcher's knife and is like tell me who
it was that set you like tell me who it
was that sent you to take us out and
what this means is that like if soldier
boy doesn't give the right answers Billy
butcher is gonna torture them all to
pieces but the big takeaway from all
this is that unlike circumstances before
where Billy a butcher was kinda like all
right you know looked like let's let's
do our thing unless lesson 218
superheroes now he's pissed and here's a
question you have to ask if all the
things that the boys were able to
achieve before was because Billy butcher
was just of the mind set up let's remind
these superheroes who's boss what in the
world is going to happen now that the
guy
actually pissed off without being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comment
explain it make sure you guys with the
sub button to become part of the rob4 if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace I want to give a shout out
to Jason see Austin s Jason s Austin H
Phillip and Austin B we have one of
Austin's and our patreon as well as G
gnosis 9/16 by the way your Rob four
rings should be on their way for our
honor guard members of the Rob core for
these special patrons your custom Rob
four rings should be on their way
they're being shipped to me after that I
will have them shipped to you stay tuned
keep your eye on patreon in your
messages and you will hear about them
coming to you thank you